the oldest stories ever told are written
in the stars regulation the Titans were
powerful but their reign was ended by
their own sons King Gramps in one yard
short in current water it was used who
created man and man's prayers fed the
gods immortality
what kind of King system is this so
where the gods not already a mortal to
Zeus invent immortality hey I know
I'll make men but let's make something
up that they can do to feed our
immortality
I know prayers those are fun into this
world a child was born but don't let the
Jesus imagery smack you in the face
during this 3d presentation
Perseus that's one way to do character
introduction I'm your father Perseus
whoa wait a minute how did Spiros know
to name his son Perseus I guess you're
going to tell me that he had heard it in
a wind or something 2010 the Year
Studios thought Sam Worthington would
become the next Brad Pitt in 2018 more
people know who Kevin Sorbo is but hey
at least we got Man on a Ledge out of
him nothing I mean you can't expect to
find a dead woman and a newborn baby
every day
oh you meant fish one day somebody's
gonna have to make a stand one day
somebody's gonna have to say enough this
is the part of Greek mythology that is
always confused and excited me there
were actually people who just one day
said we're gonna fight some goddamn gods
and they did it and they be won and most
of us are stuck with the boring
Christian God and the water divine
miracles and the people getting the fish
how would it be Greek just like the day
you came to me the storm brought me
right to you but on the day you found
him there was no storm in sight and I
have questions son I wish I had answers
I do know who Keyser söze is if you ever
need that info for some reason the
Statue of Zeus
magnificent awesome we're just in time
to watch soldiers cut it down and watch
it crash into the water right next to us
we're such a cinematically convenient
fishing boat Argo yourself bad wolf boss
I realize the gods are all-knowing but
geez that was a quick reaction do they
just have fallback setup at all possible
to find God's locations also Hades shows
up as multiple winged creatures from the
fucking ocean there seems to be two
things wrong with that
the ocean is Poseidon's own and wings
and water don't mix I learned that when
I apprentice with Satan this movie also
decided to say beside and lilybeth Percy
Jackson ah
wait a minute so hades knew which men to
kill after the statue got knocked into
the water but decided yeah why not the
innocent people on this fishing boat to
be the only instance of he survives this
curry in this film so let's just go
ahead and tack on 20 cents here for all
of them even if he is a demigod io tells
us later that he's still mortal so gosh
I created them Liam Neeson isn't killing
anyone in the seat how long must be by
Mike out 17 years always knew very
Fiennes and Liam Neeson would reunite
after Schindler's List I just thought it
would be something more dignified than
this like a fast and furious movie
there's some delightful British rom-com
or a guy who owns a shop selling hats
hates the guy across the street who
sells ties but they're both in love with
the same woman who makes themselves the
best toad-in-the-hole this side of stuff
fell upon me lon father we need the
mortals know Apollo Hades is right the
way the scene is set up I'm surprised
none of these gods have name tags just
about every bit of dialogue contains a
character name in it oh sweet looks like
they're taking him to that huge painting
on the mountain awesome we lost many men
majesty
but we have victory you're only supposed
to cut down a statue of zeus right so
really losing any men seems like non
victory the gods need us they need our
wash what do we need of them good
question
there isn't one second of this movie
devoted to what the gods actually
provide when humans bread and there was
it one second of this movie devoted to
what the gods were doing when humans
stopped praying
it took knocking down a zoo statue for
anything to happen coming this fall to
sci-fi refines is thornado
okay so we're mixing Greek and Norse
gods and he's not playing anything like
Thor but Hades nado just didn't have the
same rate you know well how do the
mortals even stand a chance against
Hades he can open his cloak and I mean
yes the power to he makes a bunch of fly
at you in ten days when the Sun all this
is happening within ten days of a solar
eclipse I didn't know what timeline
could be both arbitrary and convenient
but here we are
choose your penance Argos destruction or
sacrifice or they could just move have I
heard his prayers I don't know but I'd
love to see how that process works is
impossible if it's true you are the son
of Zeus you can save us this crowd jumps
to some serious conclusions
Hades looking at Perseus when he made
the will of your father comment when it
clearly sounded like he was just making
a general statement is literally all
they have to base their assumptions on
he's right no one should have to die for
me except maybe your mother because
she's the one who spouted off all the
because this all happened that guy did
util family maybe this is argumentative
but how did she guide him to his family
did she have power over the so called
storm that led Spiros to the place where
he found him or was she the one who
turned the coffin into a buoy he
wouldn't emerge from the bottom of the
sea and when Spiros found the baby you
said this pass yes if you were the
person orchestrating all this why would
you say pass us like this wouldn't you
be like awesome my magic worked rather
than saying paisius like a person who
finally found the baby as opposed to
guiding his journey the whole time I was
cast with agelessness so much to focus
Perseus would be amazing at cinemasins
yes decreased think he could take out a
God with a sword don't they have the
equivalent of a Merlin or at least a cue
that could invent some kind of God
killing weapon better than a pink sword
he ordered the execution of his wife and
Zeus his newborn son so we did they kill
the mother and put a living child with
her in the coffin or did they even try
to kill the kid first and did they
seriously wait nine months for her to
give birth before executing her I've
watched over you ever since waiting for
the day when you will help bring an end
to the tyranny of the gods
it's been a while since I Greek
mythology but if I remember correctly
there are many demigods so what exactly
is so special about Perseus you're
telling me that Zeus hasn't pulled the
Revenge of the Nerds sex trick a few
other times makes you think the witches
would tell us anything or they'll tell
us I'll kill them too
okay homeboy here has been a fisherman
his entire life he just got word that
he's a demigod I don't think he's ever
been trained as a fighter but
immediately after he hears IOT's story
he's absolutely sure he's an immortal
badass what is this just leave it
Ruby turns its nose up to the 1981
original with a discarded boo boo
appearance but then doesn't actually
prove itself to be any better also how
is this movie not better than the
original sure that movies entertaining
with fun Ray Harryhausen stop-motion
effects but it's not a huge obstacle to
overcome I mean you're going up against
a movie that has Harry fucking Hamlin in
the lead role and you still leave as the
worst version well at least until the
wrath of the Titans my brother and I we
know how to kill a be terrible comic
relief in a movie that doesn't need any
we have an enemy in common Zeus wouldn't
be able to hear him say this Hades was
able to hear the crack about Andromeda
being hotter than Aphrodite until I
possess my full power you will be my
weapon so is this just the Freddy vs.
Jason plotline hey if we're gonna steal
steal from something so why does Calibos
/at greasiest look like this is this the
underworld is he dead and even if he is
what exactly killed him that made him
look like this well this movie explain
any of this nonsense I believe I have an
answer to that last question you fucking
what I guess this is some sort of
demigod killing magic did he have to
transfer that orally I'm not judging
for me about destroy Zeus who you Clash
of the Titans movie turns in to throw
Zeus from the Train also I love fine but
they really should have cast someone
else in this role he is not far enough
removed from Harry Potter and this is
ripping off Harry Potter all over the
place emotions should be fluid the both
training in this movie one little scene
when someone gives total nonsense advice
somehow it works and we're supposed to
buy it just because he's Demi Moore I
mean a demigod is Russia's also I'm
assuming the production meeting went
something like this we can't have a
mechanical owl in this movie but we can
have a Pegasus right yeah a Pegasus
prints money the Pegasus no man has ever
written all i have to do is connect your
hair braid thing in him and you'll be
flying around with zoe saldana in no
time
it's a message hell watching us
apparently helping Perseus but why Zeus
gave Hades free rein to deal with the
humans and from what we can tell Zeus
knows nothing of Hades deception these
gifts make no sense I know this dude has
got some of Hades powers now but why
didn't he just wait until everybody was
asleep
Kali loss grabs Perseus by the head and
he sits there doing nothing for a full 6
seconds until Mann's can save the day
why the is he running away he just
literally tore a dude in half I don't
even understand what he needs a sword
for so Kali Mawson blood turns into
scorpions which is rip also try figuring
out how many scorpions are in this
battle since the heroes split up and
that scorpion blood is everywhere it
could be anywhere from 5 to 10 but
you'll never know just one long shot of
the area the number of scorpions and
where everybody is would do waters also
also why are they even sticking around
to fight the giant scorpions run away
and if they follow you then fight why
risk losing your army over something
that is posing a threat to no-one at the
moment also times 3 how is this not
exciting because it's not like at all a
bunch of warriors of fighting giant ask
scorpions and it might as well be a
scene of people shopping for groceries
oh yeah ex machina so guys I'm gonna
pick this moment to go get some popcorn
and candy maybe even a slushy someone
catches the spear and uses it in the
next hour let me know
this is their desert it's not so
convenient that they came to save the
day
although yeah kind of is but it's more
convenient that they came just after the
movie put in a big scorpion battle scene
so it could pretend to entertain you for
five minutes
funny this is exactly how I look when
I'm trying to resist the urge to
masturbate what is it oh it wasn't that
bad
Tom Hardy was kind of fun and it was
super ridiculous but in the end we must
pray to the one who showed us our sin
I'm definitely not helping right for the
famous seriously
why does a ferryman need quarters is he
saving up to buy a yacht the gin doesn't
try to communicate to anyone before
attempting the blue fire arm healing
method leading to yet another action
scene that I want to jettison into the
Sun did you never waited many years for
the one who will free them from the gods
good King God why didn't the Djinn try
to communicate this earlier to everyone
he could've at least tried to draw
pictures in the sand before this turned
into a misunderstanding also good thing
a person who spoke Jim showed up
randomly or they would all be dead Chaka
bolo Malfoy well we need to make up for
lost time but the scorpions aren't
moving any faster than anyone in this
crew so that's a waste of scorpions
right there when I spit in the eyes of
the gods they not smile so Draco's plan
is to give the gods hepatitis C Sabrina
the elderly testicle face which is any
excuse for this movie to go into a hyper
edit an action scene will suffice
so the plan is to find Medusa cut off
her head and use it against the Kraken
but how long is this whole journey
taking they only have 10 days and
earlier when they were in the forest
they said it would take four days to get
to the witches so now they need to find
Medusa cut off her head and get back to
fight the Kraken in another four days
which I'm gonna go ahead and declare
impossible it's almost like they know
the Pegasus is coming she's no use
against the croc we can't control them
and we take the head how do you know her
head will still turn people into stone
once it's cut off why are the chin
leaving us they believe we will all die
it's the prophecy and their dicks also
one of brothers doesn't want to pay for
any more of the special effects budget
to keep them or the scorpions around you
does mine perseus and that makes you a
god it's time you came to Olympus I
started living like one with the man
that raped his mother sounds enticing
tell me more
cuz successions this shit from the
scorpio scorpianas has got to be the
laziest way to rename something that was
obviously a scorpion next thing you know
they'll be fighting shark ETA's and
Geronimo's i know the way of course you
do why does no one question io just
showing up translating jin and knowing
the answer to everything when they don't
is it just boners
it's boners isn't it also the underworld
is just a hop skip and a jump from this
very spot we'll definitely get back in
time yay geographical convenience
once again the Jin knows something waits
until it's dramatically convenient to
reveal it and luckily the Jin knows the
rules of the funnel fairy butter bar
also sure was crazy lucky that Zeus gave
Perseus a coin before they came here
well what they have done if he didn't
would they have needed to go on another
quest to rate a vending machine was in
this movie I get that this is supposed
to be eerie and all but it really just
looks like a second-rate Disney ride
they had an underworld land this would
be the equivalent of the people mover I
cannot assist you their accursed
prevents me you might have mentioned
this to everyone before you actually
made it to the River Styx the geezers
killed you twice now Medusa shaming also
the training in this movie one little
scene where someone gives total nonsense
advice somehow it works and we're
supposed to buy it just because he's
Demi Lovato I mean a demigod also also
wouldn't everyone benefit from having
this training easiest oh is this how
they get those boners lasting more than
six hours to go away it's not working
nearly Medusa's lair so long the great
cock-blocker trust you senses don't look
this bitch in the eye Perseus graduated
from the Freddy Krueger school of
name-calling
doesn't really inspire confidence oh so
long you go the scene is so much the
balrog scene and Lord of the Rings I'm
half expecting sir Davos here to say fly
you fools at some point in the battle hi
stuff yeah because she can't move her
face down to where yours is right you
know home turning people into stone
thing her only weapon now you might be
saying guys this is just a movie and I
say welcome to cinema sins I see you're
new here they should have just let this
guy kill Medusa since he's immune to the
Medusa stare if only men could enter her
lair why was this thing that it is not a
human man allowed also kid here explodes
and somehow Medusa manages only to get
minor damage probably because this
asshole let her in on the surprise
before he blew up little Menace there's
virtually no reason man's had to
sacrifice himself here man is it ever
dramatic but seriously nothing he does
gives Perseus an advantage or weakens
Medusa in any way
now the Medusa is dead it should be
noted that none of iowa's training did
anything to help win this battle once
again any movie tries to make us believe
that a guy like cala bassa could sneak
up on and crouched behind a goddess like
io and no one would notice until the guy
stands up none of what we seen from
Perseus in this movie would make him a
good fighter by any stretch but here is
keeping up with a guy with ten times
more experience and infused with Hades
fire vomit nice time to use your gift
from the gods
couldn't use it before every fucking
person that was with you died because of
something something I don't want to use
God things but at least using it now no
way Perseus gets back in time oh the
pegasus this is the clash of the titans
version of the Lord of the Rings Eagles
leave us
release the Kraken why did soos need
everyone to leave before he gave the
order to release the Kraken
would they have stopped him does he
think they wouldn't find out also I
understand zero motivation in this movie
it's my name that calling I don't even
remember who you are
they could be expressing their love of a
Kevin Sorbo show for all I know we need
the love of toons
no you need it I survive on their fear
although the concept of thriving on
abstract human emotions has never made
quite clear by this movie at all maybe
we're surviving based on a good diet and
not smoking there is still a demigod in
Argos why did you tell him that
hey look it's Perseus on a Pegasus tell
Pythagoras I will tell the missus yeah
did Perseus just hi ah this Pegasus can
you hire a mythical creature to make it
fly faster so ends the eight-minute
screen time of the Kraken which was the
whole reason you paid money to watch
this movie and yeah he summed up no
doubt that roar was terrifying but to
sit through this whole movie to see him
go out like a chump you also plot of
this movie suggested that only a demigod
could kill the Kraken but what a Perseus
died in the underworld and only Mads was
left are you telling me that Mads
couldn't have shown the Kraken a medusa
head that makes me incredibly balanced
also also how does this Medusa thing
actually work it didn't work on the
Djinn but it did work on humans so why
exactly does it work on the Kraken other
than the movie just needs it to
andromeda falls into the water and as we
see her plunge down into it it seems
very convenient that between edits the
movie forgot all about those heavy rocks
that were following her on the way down
I'm a god I will live forever
how did Perseus know that he could
summon lightning to send 80s back to the
underworld was that part of the
conversation between he and Zeus that
didn't make it into the movies final
print the facts are coming for us how
did they even know where to go the
Pegasus tell them I cannot pick Sofia
better isn't mad you can actually be
both but why bother can we roll credits
please
it's mankind who holds the key to hit
his rise and always was well if you can
do that you went well out of your way to
help him out and if you insist on
continuing this mundane human existence
I won't have you do it alone
Zeus make Perseus and I'll talk because
it looks like Zeus made Perseus and I of
Doc I assume we call Clash of the Titans
if the gods defeated the Titans and the
Titans aren't in this entire movie then
shouldn't
become Clash of the gods or just maybe
never been made in the first place you
wear a dress and you have an animal
sidekick your princess 13 years it's
been and yet here you stand before me
yesterday shame shame shame good news
good news everyone the high ground I
don't know who you are I don't know what
you want if you are looking for a ransom
I can tell you I don't have money but
what I do have are a very particular set
of skills today we celebrate our
Independence Day Oh God
there are God's in there man ray when
someone asks you if you're a god you say
yes